was assassinated on a road
east of the iranian capital tehran he
was traveling with his bodyguards
in the car with him witnesses said that
they heard
an explosion and then gunfire the front
windscreen
was left peppered with bullet holes
attempts to save his life in hospital
failed fat carrizade was iran's
best known nuclear scientist the u.s and
israel
believe that he led the iranian
programme to develop a nuclear weapon
in 2018 benjamin netanyahu
singled him out when israel released
what it claimed
was a cache of documents proving that
iran's nuclear programme was
still running despite the jcpoa nuclear
deal
this is how dr mukhsen fakhi zadeh head
of project about put it remember that
name
fakizade this work is carried out by
sapond that's an organization
inside iran's defense ministry
and you will not be surprised to hear
that sapond is led by the same person
who led project ahmad
dr zadeh iran has been quick to point
the finger
at america and israel suggesting that
the countries want to inflame tensions
before donald trump leaves the white
house
terrorists murdered an eminent iranian
scientist today iran's foreign minister
javed zarif tweeted
this cowardice with serious indications
of israeli role
showed desperate warmongering of
perpetrators
i had heard that he was a very senior
figure and of course
he was traveling with a security detail
as well
and the whole details of the
assassination as released by iranian
news sources particularly news sources
connected to the rgc
a point to a rather elaborate operation
so this was a political assassination
[ __ ] frieza day is the second
high-profile iranian to be assassinated
this year
after general hassam solemani was killed
in a u.s drone strike
leaving baghdad airport in january iran
responded
by attacking two u.s military bases in
iraq
although fakhrazadi was the force behind
iran's nuclear program
he deliberately built up an organization
that could survive
and function without him his
assassination
whoever was behind it might have little
impact on iran's program
and it is a significant provocation iran
will likely feel the need to retaliate
alastair bunker sky news